we are pleased to have the Australian
Foreign Minister from 1988 296 and
Gareth Evans with us today welcome got
my first question to you is two years
into the war on terror the world is more
dangerous place and why is that so well
we're not doing particularly well in
terms of fighting the war on terror and
there's been more war and more terror
and not much diminution of the
phenomenon which has come to alarm us
because of the demonstration both of the
capacity of small groups to do an
extraordinary amount of damage and our
fear which is alive and still very real
that we still haven't seen the big one
the combination of that terrorist
commitment together with the utilization
of weapons of mass destruction well
that's a big question as to why we
haven't done as well as we should have
but there's no doubt about the reality
of that particular problem there are two
other problems which make the world a
scary place as well the second is the
proliferation or the imminent apparent
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and the disintegration
really of the non-proliferation regimes
which have held together remarkably well
for the last generation in particular so
far as nukes are concerned and a third
big problem is the problem of collapsed
failing failed warring states which are
proving to continue to be not only a
huge risk to their own people but the
source of concern to a lot of the rest
of the world because I've in turn their
capacity to export other problems like
terrorism like health pandemics like
refugee outflows environmental
catastrophe and so on so when you look
around the world is not a particularly
benign place at the moment and we don't
seem to have learned an awful lot about
how to handle these various problems so
you have our clan basically three type
of problem that is endangering the world
one is of course the terrorism second is
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction especially I think since the
departure of North
from the npt regime and threat that Iran
might follow suit and third is the
disintegration and of states in many
parts of the world failing States and
and failed States now let me start with
the question of terrorism now tell this
network is expanding you have said it
many times would you agree with the
Indonesian president megawati sukarno
putri who just warned and if the UN yes
last week that the United States policy
is increasing the alienation of the
Islamic people from the United States
and the West do you agree with that well
terrorism feeds above all else on
political grievance it feeds to some
extent on economic and social and
cultural grievance but it's only really
when those kinds of grievances are
somehow able to be encapsulated in
people's minds in a kind of political
framework and it's only when the scene
to be an enemy out there that things
start to get really dangerous and it's
only when in that context terrorists
find that they have a broadly
sympathetic community environment in
which to operate that the danger becomes
really real of that being
operationalized in terms of big attacks
on soft targets Western targets and I
think the biggest lesson we've learned
or should have learned over the last
little while that we've been alarmed
about this particularly since nine
eleven is that unless you really
systematically seriously address those
essentially political grievances are
being seen to be taken them seriously
you are just not going to be able to
confront effectively this phenomenon in
particular you're not going to be able
to create in the frontline States
themselves those where terrorist
activity originates you're not going to
be able to create the capacity and the
will to deal with this phenomenon you
won't have the capacity in governments
to deal with it if they feel that their
communities are not
sorting tough action against terrorists
you're not going to be able to create
the will in the community at large to
root out this phenomenon in their midst
we've seen it happening in the
Palestinian occupied territory situation
we're seeing this now happening in Iraq
where a new set of grievances have come
to to fill a vacuum we're seeing the
potential for this to develop in a
Southeast Asian context to load there I
think one should not exaggerate the
extent to which there are broadly felt
senses of grievance I think in a
Southeast Asian context Indonesian
context is very very much a minority
phenomenon and it is containable and
controllable with with sensible
strategies in the Middle Eastern context
it's a harder one to deal with because
you've got the big unresolved political
problems Israel Palestine and so on that
are just feeding this and you've got the
the performance of the u.s. in
post-conflict dirac a feeding this
you've got the whole problem of the u.s.
dealing with authoritarian regimes in
the Arab world feeding this and until
that feeding process somehow is reversed
we're going to continue to have a major
problem so when you said the problem of
us dealing with the authoritarian
regimes in the Middle East you mean that
the u.s. support for this regime is
generating some antipathy towards the
analysis is that what you are saying
well of course in the context of 911 we
know that that issue was far more a
motivator for the individuals
immediately involved than any sense of
general economic malaise or any
particular concern for the plight of the
Palestinians here it was a real
resistance to the US presence on holy
soil which was of course link to the
whole long-standing US strategy of
supporting and propping up regimes that
were not particularly attractive to
their own people I mean the issues of
much too complex to simplify in a
sentence or two but what we have here is
the fruits of a generation of policy
producing results we're deeply
uncomfortable with and what we have to
is to recognize the necessity to address
these underlying causes not just focus
on military action not just to focus on
punishment not just to focus on finding
the perpetrators because you might be
able to find them but in the process
your breeding new generations to replace
them and that's the particular problem
we're looking at right now you haven't
mentioned up against them and looks like
the Taliban is coming back kind of
strengthened and resuscitated by forces
in Pakistan and what's your solution for
that problem what's a two-fold solution
one is to get the act together in
Afghanistan itself with the far more
systematic and effective approach to
governance and security within
Afghanistan and beginning with the
effective spreading of the security
forces beyond Kabul to all parts of the
country including the Pashtun areas and
associated with that the rapid delivery
of aid reconstruction economic hope for
these people which is creating an
environment of course in which hostile
forces are once again breeding that's a
part of the answer is the internal one
in Afghanistan that has not been handled
particularly well as a hell of a lot
more to do there to get it right the
other part of the answer is to be a lot
tougher on Pakistan then the West led by
the US has wanted to be there's been far
too much willingness to take advice
value the protestations of support for
the anti-taliban cause the anti Islamist
extremists cause and not enough
recognition that there are dynamics
continuing to be at work within Pakistan
that are giving a lot of aid and comfort
to these forces and there's a necessity
to be much much tougher about the way
this military regime has been handling
itself to move to the regular problem
that's being crossing or and that's do
you want to go backwards not too bad
okay to go back to the question of the
weapons of mass destruction now the most
immediate issue before us is North Korea
and Iran and on North Korea what's your
scenario how do you think is going to
happen well I'm some kind of optimist
about the capacity for the North Korean
situation to resolve itself particularly
if the neighboring states China in
particular can be held together and
maintain a united front against the
North Koreans I think the North Koreans
were rather shocked by the way in which
they found themselves completely
isolated in the first round of six-party
talks a little while ago it's necessary
to adopt as so often in these situations
a kind of two-prong strategy a
willingness to be open and constructive
and prepared to deliver something that
the North Koreans want which is
basically security of their own regime
protection and economic support but at
the same time be prepared to be quite
tough and to bring into play now the
prospect of the sanctions the prospect
ultimately of some kind of military
strike even though we all know that
that's hugely dangerous the worry about
the way in which this issue has been
handled by the USS have been too much of
the latter the hard stuff and not enough
of the former and not enough currents
not enough carrots and we just have to
hope and I have some ground for
confidence that this message is sinking
in we just have to hope that the
negotiations the discussions are handled
in the period ahead in a way that gets
both sides of the equation on the table
but North Korea is just a symptom of a
larger problem of potential
proliferation on a much more substantial
scale of weapons of mass destruction and
what we have to ask ourselves is is why
this proliferation phenomenon is now
coming to haunt us all over again I
think there are a couple of reasons
for that one is that a number of these
regimes are quite genuine I think when
they say that the best chance they've
got of not being attacked is to move
quickly to have a nuclear capacity of
their own in that sense the casual talk
about pre-emptive strikes and that whole
strategy that we've seen in work in Iraq
has been quite counterproductive to the
larger objective or then kind of them
too well I mean it sounds too simplistic
to put it that way and that enrages
policymakers in Washington if you even
hint that this might be a problem but
you've only got to look at what these
characters are saying in Iran and North
Korea and elsewhere to realize that
psychologically this is an important
element in the gamesmanship if you like
that's going on that leads me to the
other main reason I think we're seeing
this phenomenon and again it's it's
largely psychological it's the reaction
of countries who say why should we be
put in a permanent second rank status
when the big guys those who have weapons
of mass destruction have nukes under the
existing nuclear non-proliferation
regime and are allowed to keep them when
these guys are just not being serious
themselves about even paying lip service
to the objective of ultimate elimination
I mean this was the big problem with
India and Pakistan and why did why did
India acquire nukes well partly they
said for strategic parity with China but
that never made much sense to military
people and partly they said as a
response to the anxiety with Pakistan
well that made no sense at all from a
strategic military perspective because
we were doing was creating the great
equalizer what it was really really
about was the psychology of permanent
second-rate status that you can't aspire
to one of the badges of big guy status
in the world we're not going to let you
have them at the same time as the US and
others making no gestures whatever to
indicate seriousness of purpose for
their own obligations under that treaty
regime to ultimately eliminate so the
psychology of power and the position of
the instruments
pear is very much wrapped up in this and
we have to look long and hard at that
are you seeing the same thing in Iran
that Iran feels that since Israel is
known to have New York's that they have
to have it is that is that well I think
there's an internal debate going on in
iran in which that is one current that
we have to acknowledge and recognize the
reality of I mean this utter
unwillingness in discourse about nukes
even to acknowledge the the reality of
Israel's possession of a really quite
formidable nuclear armory is just not
helping movement on this issue i means a
lot of support within the Arab Islamic
world for a genuine nuclear free zone
right across and I mean you could get
very serious dialogue about achieving
that result if only Israel we're
seriously in play as a potential
dialogue partner and participant but
it's not and so the whole can situation
or what are you going to see that is
that you do for see Iran pulling out of
NPT you like North Korea well again I
think that there's not a lot of pressure
on Iran including internally from
moderates within the country who are
struggling as in so many other spheres
in Iran to maintain some kind of
position and who do reflect I think
majority community sentiment I think
there's a chance that we'll we'll see an
uneasy sort of resolution of this issue
with IAEA inspections and optional
protocols and so on being being adopted
and embraced but with a continuing
lingering anxiety that below the surface
there is stuff continuing to go on I
think this is an issue that's going to
trouble us for some considerable time
yet and it probably will only be in the
context of a resolution of some of the
larger political issues of war and peace
in the region that will see a
satisfactory resolution of this in your
many presentations speeches you have
mentioned kind of three solutions to do
this growing crisis security one is that
you said that there has to be
institution different rules
and different strategy now if you could
elaborate a little bit on that the three
aspects well what I've said is that
first of all we've got to get a hedge
right about the relevant rules governing
the use of force the UN Charter at the
moment is an incomplete Bible in this
respect it tells us that the Security
Council can authorize military action
when there are threats to international
peace and security but we're seeing
increasingly the Security Council being
bypassed as the gatekeeper for the
application of that rule country is
going to war without Security Council
endorsement or perhaps alternately not
going to war when they when they should
because of insufficient commitment to do
that we do have an absence of rules in
particular about the circumstances in
which military intervention is
appropriate for essentially internal
situations where the wider international
threat is of second order concern and
what you are concerned about is a threat
to a country's own people as a result of
government action or inaction or a total
vacuum arising and the problem of
so-called humanitarian intervention and
the rules that are to be applicable to
govern that need a lot of thinking and
talking through because that's an issue
in which the UN Charter is almost
completely silent except to say that
value must be given to the sovereignty
and non-intervention so you really have
a problem there that's it that's a big
and a long one to resolve but let's
recognize it then you've got the
institutional problem of the Security
Council itself not only its willingness
or unwillingness to act in cases where
insured or it shouldn't but in
particular the problem of the legitimacy
of a Security Council which is
manifestly constructed on the basis of
the world as it was in 1945 not the
world as it is now but with the big guys
retaining through their veto the
capacity to stop any change to that
system to make it more visibly
legitimate and then you've got the
problem of intelligent strategies you
can have all the rules in the world you
can have all the institutional
structures in place to potentially
enforce them but unless you've got an
intelligent approach to how you address
these issues
whether it's terrorism or whether it's
weapons of mass destruction or whether
it's the problem of failed and failing
States unless you've got intelligent
strategies in place you're just not
going to make the system as work so
where do you develop this strategy if
not the Security Council which is as you
say is becoming somewhat dysfunctional
at what forum what mechanism is there
for the countries of the world to come
together developing no common strategy
well developing strategy is a function
of national processes as function of
regional and bilateral processes also a
function of global processes there's no
magic wand one can wave to get
intelligence being applied at all three
levels what we increasingly have to do
of course is get people heads around the
idea that what they do at an
international level is in fact they very
much a national interest that you can't
just distinguish between what happens
out there what happens domestically
there's nothing local there's nothing
local we'll all figure everything is
ultimately local and people have to
realize that some of the global things
we're concerned about here and acting
cooperatively in a global context even
on issues that don't seem to have an
immediate feedback into the domestic
political equation nonetheless is a
national interest that international
cooperation good international
citizenship if you like is a national
interest ranking out there with
traditional strategic security economic
trade interest because in this
globalized interdependent world of ours
there are just so many problems which
can't begin to be resolved except in the
context of cooperative multilateral
action and the necessity to be
cooperative with others on the
resolution of their problems is a
necessary prelude precondition for
getting cooperation coming back when my
problem your problem comes on the table
now just getting that mindset going as a
crucial part of getting better policies
better strategy but beyond that it's a
matter just of debating the detail of
these things when we talking about
weapons of mass destruction and
intelligence strategy is one which says
the existing nuclear power should
absolutely
forswear the research and production of
further generation nuclear weapons
because that is utterly unnecessary
militarily and utterly counterproductive
to the non-proliferation goal we should
also have a strategy which says the
existing nuclear powers should much more
clearly explicitly unequivocally commit
themselves to an ultimate objective of
elimination and sounds serious about it
not half-hearted about it because unless
they do that the psychology the
testosterone psychology that generates
so much anxiety to play into this club
elsewhere is going to continue when it
comes to terrorism you've got to have a
much more intelligent focus on a need to
give preeminence to the resolution of
the underlying political grievances
you've got to have much more preeminence
and prominence given to solutions which
focus on building capacity building will
in the front nine states now again all
we can do is to hope that through
existing national processes and
international process as we can we can
get more intelligent debate creating
some new institutional structure or
trying to who are hoping for some magic
wand to be waived by someone to fix it
is not going to happen it's just an
ongoing nagging noring process terrific
doing great thank you very much Thank
You them